- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm dean here at the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I'm delighted to welcome you
all to this afternoon's Davis
Lecture to be delivered by
novelist Garth Risk Hallberg.
At Radcliffe, scholars,
scientists, and artists
pursue innovative
research and engage
in cutting-edge creative work
across disciplinary boundaries.
We are also dedicated to sharing
the fruits of their study
with public audiences through
lectures, conferences,
and exhibitions.
Each year we adopt
a thematic focus
for some of our programming.
This year's theme is
urbanism-- a topic
that draws together
students and faculty
from many parts of
Harvard and connects them
with public officials
and creative artists.
One such artist is
today's speaker,
Garth Risk Hallberg, author
of the highly acclaimed novel
City on Fire.
This lecture is
also very special,
because it is the first of
this year's Davis Lectures.
The Davis Lecture series was
established by Kim and Judy
Davis, and I am thrilled to have
Kim right here in the first row
with us in the audience.
Kim and Judy are enthusiastic
supporters of the Radcliffe
mission to bring leading
thinkers to Cambridge
for the purpose of tackling
important questions,
whatever the field.
We have two more Davis
Lectures to look forward
to this academic year.
Brian Greene, a physicist
and mathematician
at Columbia University
will speak on Thursday,
February 9th at 4:15.
And Dava Sobel, a highly
regarded science writer,
will give a talk on Thursday,
April 13th at 4:15 as well.
Today's lecture is called
Organized Complexity, the Novel
and the City.
Garth certainly knows something
about organization, complexity,
and novels.
City on Fire is more
than 900 pages long,
and I did bring my copy here,
in case you haven't seen it.
So you don't have to
just take me at my word.
And it is not just
about any city.
It is about a specific city
at a specific moment in time--
New York City in the
tumultuous decade of the 1970s.
Now, in addition to being the
dean here at the Radcliffe
Institute, I am also a
20th century US historian
in the Harvard
history department.
So I'm going to put
on my historian's hat
and introduce you to
New York in the 1970s
from an historian's
perspective, to help set
the scene for Garth's lecture.
First, let's back up a bit.
The decades following World
War II witnessed the most
sustained economic
growth in US history.
Wealth grew.
Inequality shrunk.
Coming out of the New Deal of
the 1930s and 1940s, labor,
business, and
government officials
all shared the assumption
that government
and the private sector both
should play important roles
in creating broad-based
economic prosperity
for the benefit of individuals,
corporations, and government.
Well-paid workers and secure
union and corporate jobs--
it was argued-- would
protect the purchasing power
of their fellow citizens through
their own mass consumption.
Moreover, leaders all
presumed that economic growth
and post-war affluence
would go on forever.
New York City shared
that confidence.
It was home to public
hospitals, to zoos,
to well-stocked
public libraries,
an affordable public transit
system, and a tuition-free City
University.
Its public sector even
included some social safety net
for people who were down
and out on their luck,
and it enjoyed adequately
resourced police
and fire departments.
But just below the surface, New
York did have serious problems,
and access to all
of those amenities
varied along lines
of race and class.
Only for white middle class
and some working class
New Yorkers was the post-war
era a time of ease and optimism.
In the late 1950s,
industrial production
scaled back nationwide,
particularly
in eastern urban
centers like New York.
The garment industry started
to abandon Manhattan.
Electronic factories,
food production plants,
and other small and
mid-sized employers
in the city's very diversified
economy began to shut down,
eliminating good
working class jobs.
Activity along New
York's busy ports
declined, and with it,
employment opportunities
for the thousands who made
their living on the docks.
To make matters
worse, the closure
of the Brooklyn Navy
Yard and other New York
military installations
cost the metropolitan area
tens of thousands of jobs.
By 1969, full scale
recession had set in.
Meanwhile, many New
York corporations
began to join in
the nationwide trend
of relocating to the suburbs.
Companies like Pepsi and
Shell Oil, to name just two,
just moved their corporate
headquarters out of the city.
And as companies left, they took
their tax dollars-- as well as
their middle class
workforces, whose tax
contributions were then
lost to the city's coffers.
New York responded
to its shrinking tax
base by turning to
finance to pay the bills.
The city sold bonds and
borrowed from private banks
to pay for basic services.
Then as the 1970s progressed,
interest rates spiked.
In 1975, bankers warned
the United States Treasury
and members of
Congress that New York
was about to be shut
out of credit markets.
New York City's mayor and
the governor of New York
traveled to Washington
DC to request federal aid
for New York City.
Without it, basic services
would have to be suspended.
The Ford administration's
refusal to extend aid
was immortalized in a famous
newspaper headline that read,
"Ford to city, drop dead."
New York City plummeted
into a fiscal crisis.
It cut 63,000 municipal
employees from its payroll,
reduced the number of teachers
by 25%, hiked fares and fees,
suspended building projects,
reduced garbage collection,
and shuttered police
and fire stations.
The cuts brought two
priorities into direct conflict
with each other-- namely,
fiscal responsibility
and social responsibility.
Decades earlier, labor,
business, and government
officials had all
assumed that these two
types of responsibility
could go hand in hand,
but in the crisis
of the 1970s, it
seemed like New York City was
forced to choose between them.
The choice would turn out to be
a burning question, literally.
Arson raged through parts of
the city, like the South Bronx.
Some commentators accused
public housing residents
of setting the fires
themselves, but the evidence
points strongly to
private real estate
interests trying to cash
in on insurance payouts.
Hints of such schemes
appear in City on Fire.
And then when it seemed
like things could not
get much worse, lightning struck
a Con Edison power substation
on the Hudson River.
The whole city blacked
out, just at the time when
police and fire departments
were being slashed,
which dramatically hindered
an effective city response.
This is the New York City
we confront in City on Fire.
For centuries, the
tools of the novelist
have helped us better
understand cities.
Charles Dickens
brought to life London
in the 18th and 19th centuries.
Victor Hugo painted
vivid portraits
of 18th century Paris.
Richard Wright revealed
a 1930s Chicago
as few readers had seen it.
Salman Rushdie
immortalized Bombay
in the first decades
of Indian independence.
Doubtless you have
your own favorites.
Garth Risk Hallberg's novel City
of Fire joins this tradition,
and we are fortunate to
have him with us here today
to talk about it.
Now, please join me in
welcoming Garth Hallberg.
- Hi, I'd like to thank
Radcliffe for having me,
and I'd like to think Liz
for that warm introduction.
I can say I haven't
done a lot of these,
but I've done enough
to tell you that it's
rare to actually learn something
when you're being introduced.
So that's a great
pleasure for me.
I'd like to offer a
preemptive apology for what's
about to follow.
As a writer, you start out
kind of aggrieved at the fact
that nobody cares
what you think.
But after a while,
you get almost used
to it-- almost attached to it.
There's a certain freedom in
being ignored and marginalized.
At any rate, this whole genre
of public talk is new for me
and just conceptually
kind of bizarre.
Last month, Bruno Latour, the
eminent philosopher of science
was here, and I wonder what
illumination I can possibly
offer about cities, or
culture, or life on earth
that can stack up
against Bruno Latour.
And yet, I entered this
date in my calendar
back in January, because the
central theme at Radcliffe
this year is one
close to my heart,
and one very close to the heart
of the novel City on Fire.
As the date has
approached, I've been
beset by terrors
and night sweats,
wondering where to even begin.
But this last week
has been-- what's
the word I'm looking
for-- clarifying.
It's been clarifying.
It's caused me to
completely trash
the bit about Dickens
and Virginia Woolf
and the bit about Goedel's
incompleteness theorem,
but it has been clarifying.
Where I want to
begin, in fact, is
with that horrible red
and blue map of America
I keep seeing
everywhere-- or would keep
seeing if I could bear to look.
Now, anyone with a passing
acquaintance with demography
knows that this map is
profoundly misleading.
It gets treated as evidence of
a lopsided division between what
I believe Dr. Ben Carson called
the coastal elites on the one
hand and quote "we the
people" on the other.
Don't grasp the distinction
or don't accept it?
Just look at the map.
Coastal elites, tiny,
tiny, tiny, tiny.
We the people, vast, vast.
And just semantically,
who would dare
to argue with we the people?
Who doesn't feel like
giving the elites
that last shove into the sea?
But with all due respect to
the map and to Dr. Carson,
the truth is that a
coalition of working class
swing voters, business
minded burghers,
traditional cultural
conservatives,
rock ribbed retirees, and--
yes-- some misogynists,
and xenophobes, and
ethnonationalists
doesn't in 2016 add up to
a silent majority-- or even
a silent plurality.
By an admittedly thin
but substantial margin,
it's still a vocal minority.
As right-leaning
coalitions have been
in every presidential
election since 1988,
with the exception of
2004, and surprisingly
in most congressional
elections too.
Given the one-person
one-vote principle,
it'd be far more accurate for
the infographic to feature
an auditorium of 100
people-- 47 of them
in red t-shirts and
48 of them in blue.
Now, 47 out of 100 is
still a lot of t-shirts.
And the Madisonian system
makes generous allowances
for the rights of the minority.
One wonders if those allowances
will be respected by those now
coming into power.
But talk of the
largest voting bloc
of Americans as a tiny
elite, opposed to we
the people or-- god
help us-- the heartland,
is rank propaganda.
And treating it as such
would be a healthy first step
in the national pogrom avoidance
program I think all parties can
agree is worth pursuing.
In the contest for which end
of the political spectrum
is more in touch with
hard work or suffering,
or more out of touch
with conditions
on the ground, or cozier
with power, or more American,
there can be no winners.
In a more particular
sense, though,
and the one in which I think
the infographic was originally
conceived, the red-blue map
remains intensely revealing.
And that is that the
support for a center
left liberalism,
keen to blunt but not
transform the rough
edges of capitalism--
however large that support
is in democratic terms--
remains concentrated in
major metropolitan areas.
I imagine nowhere more
concentrated than right here
in Cambridge, Mass.
Probably nowhere more
concentrated than in this room
at this moment.
And conversely, support for
a center right or right wing
agenda has its base outside
those concentrations.
It is likely that the
center exists somewhere
in the suburbs, and
that the red gets deeper
the sparser the population is.
Now, ever since 2000, when
the red-blue map first reared
its head.
There's been a lot of
theorizing about the origins
of this geographic split.
There's the theory
of self-segregation--
that on both sides
of a partisan divide,
people are choosing
increasingly to cluster
with the like minded.
And there's obviously
some truth to that.
But it doesn't strike
me as a new development.
It's worth noting, also, that
the self-segregation theory
flatters the assumptions,
both of urban liberals who
like to think of small towns
as havens for racists gun nuts,
and of small town dwellers
who think of urban liberals
as smug self-satisfied
hypocrites.
So I'm not sure how far
self-segregation gets us
as a practical analysis.
There's also the theory,
convenient for the right
and gaining steam on the left,
that the uneven distribution
of voters somehow maps neatly
onto the uneven distribution
of income, that the latte
liberals have prospered
at the expense of
factory workers.
Certainly, the cultural
shibboleths of the tech set
and the hipsterati,
the conflation
of progressivism and
consumerism have done nothing
to undercut this idea.
And there is a
generational sense
of classes being
formed and dissolved--
with maybe the
beard as a floating
signifier of some kind.
But Portlandia remains
a vanishingly small
political force, and
to me the conflation
of the Obama voter and the
one percenter is a canard.
Suburbs in small
towns and rural areas
have their elites, too,
whose fortunes rise and fall
with elites everywhere.
And I can tell you
from experience,
a lot of those people
vote Republican,
as do plenty of captains
of industry and finance.
More interesting to me and
more plausible is the idea
that perhaps there
is a different kind
of causal nexus, that living
in cities somehow gives rise
to certain values
and assumptions,
rather than resulting from them.
As would, in this
analysis, living
in small town or rural America.
The idea is that urban
and non-urban America
are not even really
speaking the same language,
because they're
describing what feels
like two different worlds.
Now, it doesn't logically or
morally follow from the fact
that there are two ways of
seeing a problem that both
must be equally valid.
But I don't really want to use
this time to pass judgment over
whether someone's right
and someone's wrong.
Rather, having been lucky enough
to spend half my life in one
part of the map and
half in another,
and to have now spent 10
years of my life thinking
about cities, I thought this
would be an interesting time
to try to excavate
some of the principles
and values that
living in a city--
or writing a 900 page
novel about one--
foreground in the
human experience, how
those principles and values are
rooted in urban experience--
especially the experience of
my particular city, New York--
and also in the experience of
reading and writing novels,
because what I
found as I wrote was
a kind of peculiar resonance
between the novel and the city.
That resonance, that for
me has been the only way
to know I'm in the
ballpark of a human truth,
my hunch as a New Yorker is
that some of these principles
and values will be at first
blush familiar and reassuring
to an audience of Bostonians.
The real value in
articulating them
is in bringing us down into
the complex soil where they're
rooted, because understood
in their deepest
sense, these
principles and values
are not only rich and
satisfying but disconcerting and
uncomfortable to live
with and challenging--
as is any human truth.
In fact, it's going
to be my contention
that humanism in the age of
neoliberal disarticulation
has become complacent
precisely in its eagerness
to ignore the more challenging
underpinnings of its own value
system, and that attempting to
look at them more honestly--
and indeed to
confront them-- would
go a long way toward explaining
the massive blind spots that
have evidently come to
afflict city dwellers,
and toward getting us out of
the deep democratic shit I'm
pretty sure we're now in.
Maybe that's what
novels are for.
Now, one of those principles--
I'm going to argue--
involves the primacy of the
concrete, the situational,
the contextual, the local over
the big giant abstraction.
Let me try to ground my
later remarks by talking
to you, first specifically,
about where I'm coming from,
about cities, and
non-cities, and how
I came to write City on Fire.
I grew up in eastern
North Carolina
in a town called Greenville,
which at the time
was so insignificant that no
one really knew where it was.
Later after I'd left, I'd
mention the town to people
and they'd go, oh,
right, Greenville.
And 9 times out of 10,
they'd be confusing it
with its larger and more
glamorous cousins Greensboro
in NC and Greenville, SC.
Oh, right, they'd say.
Greenville, I think I went
to a cousin's wedding there.
I'd say right down
the road from Rawling?
Yes, they'd say, and I'd
say, nope, that's Greensboro.
Or I'd say big view
of the mountains?
And they'd say, yeah.
And I'd say that's
Greenville, South Carolina.
But Greenville, North Carolina--
at least the Greenville
of my childhood-- was 18,000
people, some strip malls,
a land-grant college,
and a fading downtown.
Surrounded by miles
and miles of fields,
a little pin stuck into the
map of down East, tobacco road.
For reasons I still
don't understand,
I didn't feel entirely
at home there.
I can remember even at 5 or 6
feeling like a fish flopping
around on a dock,
unaware that there
was such a thing as an ocean.
But a lot of it felt
to me to have something
to do with the town's
conservatism, which I don't
mean in a political sense.
I mean something closer
to the town's sense
of what makes a
character and how
to keep a community from
being swallowed back
into the wilderness
that surrounds it.
In Greenville in the early
part of the Reagan Revolution,
there was still an old-fashioned
sense that if you were a boy,
you grew up to follow whichever
of the five acceptable paths
the men in your family had laid.
And if you are a girl, you
had your own prescribed paths.
And how you measured your
value, was by how closely
you hewed to the channel.
That's if you were white.
If you were black, there
was a different set
of channels to follow.
And any tensions
that may have arisen
along the various frontiers
of race, and sex, and class,
and personality were
not to be spoken of
or acknowledged, but suppressed.
The very existence of a
frontier was suppressed.
Well, that wasn't
going to work for me.
Like many a passionate reader,
I found my first escape
in reading.
Actually, I'm not
sure if the reading
was an escape from
the alienation
or a cause of
further alienation.
Probably, it was both.
But, oh, it was amazing to me at
7 or 8, the cover of every book
was like a door.
You opened it and walked
right across the threshold.
And though I loved and
love all manner of fiction,
the books I loved most then
were those that built a world.
I remember the
three or four months
I spent inside CS Lewis'
Narnia, which of course enacts,
in its central image of
the wardrobe, that very act
of opening a door
and walking through.
I remember devouring
the hobbit in the course
of a single 15-hour car
ride, lying unbelted
in the way back of
the station wagon--
because those were
the days, right--
and emerging at a rest
stop, as from dreams,
unsure which world I was in--
the deep South or Middle Earth.
But there was
another fantasy world
I encountered in those
early years-- no less
fantastical or vividly colored.
I found it in EB
White's Stuart Little,
and again in Harriet the
Spy, and in Judy Blume,
and in From the Mixed-up Files
of Mrs. Basil E Frankweiler.
It was called New York City,
and like any fantasy world,
it was filled with
eccentric characters
crossing each other's paths.
It held a myriad of adventures,
of quests, the fabled 8 million
stories.
But New York also had a
few unusual properties.
First, unlike Middle
Earth or Narnia,
you could look it up
in the trucker's atlas.
You could-- at least
in theory-- go there.
Second, unlike Middle
Earth or Narnia,
it wasn't the property
of any one writer.
Anyone-- perhaps including even
me-- could begin a story there,
without subtracting from
or reducing the whole.
It didn't belong to anyone
and so belonged to everyone.
A final curious thing
about New York I noticed.
You opened to the
copyright pages of books,
and they all come from New York.
John Updike has that great line
about reading The New Yorker
as a kid.
He talks about a
great river of print
flowing from 42nd Street to
Shillington, Pennsylvania.
And that's something
like what I felt
when I realized that that's
where the books come from.
I think I imagined skyscrapers
made out of paperbacks
stacked on their sides.
And I thought, that must
be the best place ever.
Later on, I became a
disaffected teenager,
in a way that seemed to me
then completely unprecedented
in the history of the world.
Greensville had
gone from feeling
like a backwater to
feeling like a prison,
and Stuart Little wasn't
quite a big enough channel
to run my feelings
through anymore.
I found my refuge in my new
obsessions-- poetry and punk
rock.
Both of them seemed to
present alternative ways
of being in the world.
In my poetry reading,
I was promiscuous.
In no other aspect of my
life as a teenager can
I say that but in
my poetry reading.
I read Dante.
I read Tennyson.
I read Whitman,
Dickinson, Ashbury.
I wrote poetry, very
badly, but in a way that
got me interested
in the avant-gardes
of the 1950s, '60s, and '70s,
which led back to New York.
And thought some of the most
vital punk rock of that era
was coming out of the
post-hardcore scene
in Washington DC, there was also
this place at the roots of punk
that likewise
pointed to New York.
That New York-- the New York
of Lou Reed, and Patti Smith,
and Jim Karole,
and Ted Berrigan,
and Joey Ramone-- wasn't
the gleaming postwar edifice
that EB White had painted,
but something equally
enchanted-- a place
that was entirely
edge, entirely frontier, a
place where all the tensions
were right on the surface.
This meant, on one hand,
that it was dangerous.
You could get stabbed at your
locker or hassled up town.
You could overdose or cross
paths with a psycho killer
outside beneath
the marquee moon.
And I think I was fascinated
even then by the fact
that this incredible outpouring
of creative expression
in poetry, in punk, in hip
hop, in painting, performance
art-- this thing that gave us
much of what was culturally
interesting in the world of
the 1990s and much of what's
culturally interesting
now-- came out
of a few blocks of downtown
Manhattan at this period,
as if a garden were to
come bursting through
with some broken
squares of sidewalk.
How could fear and freedom,
creation and destruction
live so closely together?
On weekends and in the
summer starting at 16,
I began going up to DC, which I
could reach in 3 and 1/2 hours,
pushing 75 miles an hour
in my dad's old car,
to see punk shows and
crash on people's couches,
and effectively
run away from home.
I'd made some friends there
through poetry and punk.
But there was also
this girl I'd met
who lived four hours
further on by bus or by car
in New York City.
And that's how it ended up in
the city for the first time
20 years ago last month.
I was chasing a girl.
Now it's rare to
dream of something
and then attain it in
real life without a tinge
of disappointment
at its actuality.
But in this case,
New York seemed
much as I had dreamed it.
Perhaps this was because
I hadn't romanticized away
the tensions, contradictions,
and mysteries of the city.
I had romanticized them.
And in the 90s, maybe even
more so than in the '70s,
they were everywhere you looked.
It was an amazing point
in the life of the city.
This was the early Middle
Giuliani era in New York,
and he was still refining
the methods of social control
and oppressive banality I think
we can all look forward to
in the near future.
But beneath his
efforts to clean up
the city were traces
of the wilder, dirtier,
and more heterodox city
he was trying to erase.
I remember stepping off the
bus in the Port Authority bus
terminal.
The first thing you'd
see across 8th Avenue
were the glowing neon signs
of the peep shows-- Peepland
and Peeporama.
And then way down
42nd Street, you'd
see the sign for the Lion
King-- these two things,
right next to each other.
And the tension, the sense of
layering, was magic for me.
I was captivated, too,
by the dense parfait
of class, and race, and
age, and sexual milieu.
[? SEAM ?] If you were
17, and a would-be poet,
and willing to
say yes, you could
hit a reading at a private
high school uptown,
jump a turnstile, smoke some
pot with a future member
of The Strokes, go to
a bar in the Village,
and end up sleeping on the
roof of some artist's hovel
on Avenue C. You could go to
a rave in the Brooklyn Bridge,
or to gay karaoke, or
check out bondage gear,
or become a traveling jester
for an hour with the yuppie pub
crawl, or spend a memorable
Sunday morning being toured
around Harlem by a
smart and homeless
and possibly schizophrenic
woman named Deborah Little.
You can even actually climb to
the top of the Brooklyn Bridge
then.
I'm not saying I did,
because I'm not sure
if this is being taped,
but one could climb
the top of the Brooklyn Bridge.
No one would stop you.
And something changed
in my writing.
For a week after
that first visit--
and unconnected from it,
I thought-- my poetry
deepened and became real.
And then after a week in
which I wrote the only seven
real poems I'll probably ever
write, the gift just left me.
I knew it had left me that.
It wasn't coming back no matter
how many subsequent weekends I
spent in the city.
I ended up not making it
to New York for college,
on account of being
unable to afford it.
I went to St. Louis
instead on a scholarship,
and wrote four years'
worth of bad prose,
and met and chased the girl
who would become my wife.
After we graduated, she
wanted to go to grad school,
and we thought, great, now
we'll move to New York.
But it turned out, she couldn't
afford grad school there,
either.
She got a fellowship to go to
the University of Maryland,
just outside of Washington DC.
And I remember thinking,
well, the city will wait.
The girl probably will not.
So we moved to DC.
That was the summer of
2001, the first summer
of the rest of my life,
the beginning for me
of the adult world.
And there came a day that fall,
maybe six weeks into my first
full time job, when it suddenly
seemed like maybe New York
wouldn't wait, like maybe New
York wouldn't be there the next
day, like maybe Washington
wouldn't, and life wouldn't.
Like all the things
I loved and taken
for granted were in fact
radically contingent,
hovering on the
verge of destruction.
I'm going to skip over the bit
about how the novel came out
of this experience,
maybe it'll will come up
in the discussion portion.
But just suffice it to say that
mixed in with all the grief
and trauma I felt--
and many of us
here felt-- having watched in
real time as thousands of lives
were impossibly snuffed out,
was a different kind of grief,
as if the city itself
had been snuffed out.
And a question
about what exactly
it would have meant for New
York this beacon to disappear.
What about New York was unique,
and sacred, and unreplicatable?
Which was something like asking
what was it about this city
that I loved?
And at some point after
spending a lot of time up there,
bearing witness, and just
before I moved there for good,
I had this flash of
inspiration that everything I'd
been seeing, and feeling,
and wondering about in 2001,
2002, 2003, wanted
to express itself
through this enormous
story of 1975, 1976, 1977,
that other time, when the
city, as you heard from Liz
was broken, and vulnerable, and
open, and hovering on the edge.
I worked through
the first draft,
trying to preserve in a
way the sense of confusion.
The important thing
was not to propose
an answer of the
city's unique meaning
but to gesture
toward the question.
Nonetheless, the book
started to teach me things,
as books will when
you're writing them--
or possibly the city
was teaching me,
or maybe it amounts
to the same thing.
These are the
values or principles
I was trying to gesture
at earlier, the things we
urban dwellers can't easily
forget but also can't
seem to quite remember.
And to talk about
a few of them, I'm
going to borrow some
vocabulary from a book that
became very important to
me right around the time
I started the second draft,
when I finally got around
to reading it.
That book is Jane
Jacobs' The Death
and Life of Great
American Cities.
In no way is City on Fire
a programmatic engagement
with Jane Jacobs' ideas.
In fact, I may be
misreading them
to suit my own purposes, which
is always a productive strategy
for a novelist.
But I can say that
her book-- or possibly
my impressionistic
misreading of it--
gave me a way to
understand things
that, when I was imagining
the book into existence,
I felt I was
discovering on my own.
So here they are.
Principle one, it
must be concrete.
This is an intuitive value for
the fiction writer, I think,
yet one that a long novel will
insist upon, each time you
start to forget it.
Life takes place, not in the
abstract, but in the concrete.
Not in rules, bus in practices.
With students, I like to
use the word incarnate.
Novelistic truth is
a function of what
is given flesh in the
text, through detail,
point of view voice, drama,
and above all context.
And because a novel offers
room for multiple contexts,
it's a unique vehicle
for paradox and irony,
for holding conflicting
ideas in the mind.
I like the example of Henry
James' Washington Square.
The heroine's father, Dr.
Sloper, brings into the novel
a bunch of moral
precepts, which are
in the abstract unassailable.
Yet confronted with the concrete
circumstances of his daughter's
position, he ends
up seeming to us,
the readers, profoundly wrong.
It's also interesting
and connected
to concreteness to think
of modernists like Becket
or Gertrude Stein, who
in various projects
attempt to evacuate from the
novel much of its tropism
for what's concrete
and specific.
But Beckett's work,
even Beckett's work,
gets its life from the pebble
in the pocket, the lone tree,
and above all from its
incredible solidity of voice.
The primacy of the concrete over
the abstract has historically
been a little harder for urban
theorists to admit, in part,
because they carry a burden
that novelists don't.
People don't come to novels
to have their problems solved.
They go to planners.
But Jane Jacobs'
work in reacting
to the excesses of abstraction
in her nemesis Robert Moses
and in architects Le
Corbusier, reminds us
that cities too are a form
of reasoning in concrete.
They defeat in their specificity
and dependence on context
all top down efforts
to rationalize them.
All you have to do to
see how specifics insists
on themselves, to do
it Jane Jacobs did
and what some novelists do, is
spend a week carefully watching
a city block, or a subway
platform, or an elevator.
There may be various
rules and regulations,
but there will also
emerge from the context
of sorts of unspoken pacts,
compromises, arrangements,
workarounds.
The same is true of
Nabokovian attempts
to treat your characters
like galley slaves.
If they're real characters,
they will surprise you
in their specificity.
The concrete always wins.
Principle two, it
must be diverse.
Diversity is often
treated nowadays
as a commodity, a
kind of managed good.
But in fact, as
Jacobs shows, anytime
you gather specific and concrete
parts into the arrangement
we call a city, diversity
naturally assert itself.
There's an odd
fact about plumbing
that a perfectly
smooth pipe will not
allow the water to flow down.
You have to have
roughness of texture.
And in engineering, a
bridge of sufficient length
that maintains identical
tension at all points
will break the first time
a car drives across it
or the wind blows the wrong way.
And so in some strange way, it's
dangerous to treat diversity
as a decorative item
or a token of virtue.
It's not a luxury product.
It's a necessity.
This is true of novels too and
of long novels in particular.
It's possible to achieve
an effect of ruthless
unity in something as short
as, say, Meloy or Paula Fox's
desperate characters.
But if you look
close, you'll start
to see the irregularities,
the diversities, the cracks.
And in a long novel, even the
illusion of ruthless unity
is an impossibility.
It took me a lot of trial
and error to figure this out.
A 900 page novel that maintained
the illusion of ruthless unity
you get in Meloy would cause the
reader to blow her brains out.
Even Beckett doesn't
maintain it in his trilogy.
Variation-- I mean, I think, in
the third part of the trilogy,
the narrator is a worm
living in a flower pot
or something like that?
Variation and diversity is key.
And I discovered as I
wrote and revised the novel
that the more I could get
scenes, and characters,
and sentences to be
unlike each other,
the more the novel would
move and have resilience.
Principle three,
and this is going
to sound like an about-face
from the previous point.
It must connect.
Somehow, for all the various
and discrete people, and images,
and scenes that make up a
living novel and a living city,
there has to be patterning, a
sense of unifying commonality
animating the whole.
It's easiest to see this
in the field of literature.
A novel of pure randomness,
something like Andy Warhol's
A not a novel which has readers.
And so in the
non-abstract framework
I'm arguing we should adopt,
not really a novel at all.
Whereas in something like
Jonathan Franzen's The
Corrections, you have dozens
of patternings running
through the diverse material,
binding it together--
from family connections
among the characters,
to somewhat more
mechanical connections
among with subplots, to a
delicate leitmotif of hands.
It is interesting that we
rebel as contemporary readers
against the bit where the
pharmaceutical company that
makes Alfred's
medication turns out
to be connected somehow with
the demise of his train company
or whatever.
To us the kinds of connections
that Dickens delighted
in making in his
novels of London,
the various past crossings
and coincidences,
feel artificial,
Victorian, unrealistic.
Perhaps they don't emerge from
the specific and the concrete
but read as imposed
abstractions.
But I wonder, to play
devil's advocate,
whether this speaks to
some alteration in how
we urban dwellers move
through our cities
and in what kinds of connections
we open ourselves to.
I can literally
remember a night at 17,
when I started out
on Central Park West,
in the very nice apartment
of an investment banker,
and ended up on the roof
of an artist's squat,
on Avenue C. Come
to think of it,
I remember talking to a
guy on the next roof over.
And he turned out to be
the friend of a friend
and also the son of the former
bishop of Washington DC.
Finally, on the
principles and values
of the novel and the city, I'll
quote Wallace Stevens' poem
Notes Toward a Supreme Fiction.
"It must change."
Actually, let's
just call this what
it is, a principle
of life itself--
change, change, change.
I think when we talk about a
novel having a sense of life,
we're really talking about it
having a sense of modulation,
of dynamism, of change, or we
wouldn't read pass page one.
Certainly, any
time I found myself
getting stuck in this novel,
whether between sentences
or between chapters, I learned
to tell myself accept it.
Something has to change.
Cities too are, as a
character in the book
puts it, sites of
concentrated change.
And of course we know this.
And still we complain about
the glassy condo towers,
the disappearance of the mom
and pop shop, the growing
crappiness of public transit.
Or like Edith
Wharton's characters
in The Age of Innocence,
sitting around in 1850,
talking about how
New York is so over.
We retreat, like my
characters, into fantasies
of stopping time at
some ideal point,
rather than opposing the
changes we don't like
with our own vision of change.
I suppose change is the hardest
of these principles to accept,
because it isn't
a one shot deal.
You have to accept
it anew every day.
You have to keep changing.
And this is-- not
incidentally-- what
I think people get profoundly
wrong about Jane Jacobs,
and what we tend to get
profoundly wrong about cities,
and urban experience, and maybe
literature, and politics, too.
I came to Jane
Jacobs with the sense
of a desirable what
of urban planning,
a static target-- you know,
mixed use development,
human size streetscape, the
magic elixir of diversity,
all the stuff that's become
canonical, even if-- as I've
been trying to point
out-- we recoil
from some of its challenges.
But The Death and Life
of Great American Cities
is a funny book in that
it's built inductively
rather than deductively.
The big idea tying the
whole thing together
only comes at the end.
So if you don't read to
the very last chapter,
you never quite grasp the
why and the how of what
Jacobs is arguing,
and you never quite
get that she's not proposing
a vision of stasis,
but a beautiful and terrifying
vision of constant change.
Her final chapter is called
The Kind of Problem a City Is,
and it underpins all her
talk about diversity,
and specificity, and connection.
And it's where I'd like
to leave you today,
as we turn to the discussion
part of this program.
In it, Jacobs
draws a distinction
between two kinds of systems--
disorganized complexity
and organized complexity.
The names can be a
little bit misleading.
Disorganized
complexity, basically,
means a system whose
variables can be treated
in isolation from each other.
Statistical methods,
computers, data
are excellent for
analyzing such systems.
Think of a life insurance
company for example.
The life of each
subscriber is a variable,
but barring some
national catastrophe,
the life expectancy of a
subscriber in California
will have very
little interaction
with a life expectancy of
subscriber in Nebraska.
And so they can be treated
separately in isolation.
And various actuarial
principles and laws
of averages that I
frankly don't understand
will lead to
predictable behavior
for the system as a whole.
The human body, suggests
Jacobs, is an example
of organized complexity--
dense with variables,
each of them interacting
in complex and dynamic ways
with the others-- recursions,
feedback loops, paradoxes.
This is why it's
impossible to speak
of a risk-free
medical intervention.
You put a cast on a broken
leg, which is great,
but a whole range of
variables from mental health
to cardiac health is affected
by limiting the range of motion.
It's a delicate dance of
nodes and connections.
And to change one piece
is to change the whole.
It is Jane Jacobs' great insight
that no matter how useful
the drive toward more and
greater data has proven,
a city is the latter kind of
problem, a problem of organized
complexity, and that trying
to isolate and then engineer
its various facets in a
static and abstract way
will only take you so far.
It is the methods of the life
sciences, biology, of medicine,
rather than the laws of physics,
that are applicable here,
because again every
facet is knit together
in an organic whole.
This happens to be an almost
perfect description of the kind
of problem a novel is.
And this homology is perhaps
the single biggest reason
that from Dickens, and Eliot,
and Balzac, and Tolstoy,
to Mrs. Dalloway, and
Herzog, and Underworld,
and the Emperor's
Children, the novel
has been such a perfect
tool for analyzing a city
and getting at its meaning.
For if a novel is to
have any life at all,
it will ultimately reveal to
its inhabitants the creativity
and comfort, security and
freedom, order and vitality,
innovation and tradition,
as well as all of the values
we would like to think
we approve and espouse--
the local, the diverse, the
connected, the changing,
for example-- are not
discrete variables that we
can manipulate independently.
They are linked together
in a complex network,
and attempting to manage
any of them in a vacuum
will have costs
for all the others
and for the system as a whole.
You impose a more
rigid narrative.
You cost your people
their freedom.
You liberate your
people completely,
and the story
holding them together
decays into incoherence.
You attend overmuch
to aesthetic beauty,
and you lose the sense of life.
You hew too closely to
life as it has always been,
and you lose all
possibility of beauty,
all possibility of change.
And so, ultimately, the
idea of a closed society--
whether the a
society of tradition
or the society of virtue--
is as oxymoronic as the idea
of a perfect novel
or a perfect life.
There can be no
possibility without risk,
no creation without
destruction, and no
getting through the whole thing
without setbacks, reversals,
hope, and pain.
You attempt to pick
and choose among these,
to drive toward unity,
perfection, abstraction,
fixity, is a very
human response,
whether it's coming from
the left or from the right,
from red America or
from blue America.
But though talking
heads said that heaven
is a place where
nothing ever happens,
this utopia doesn't sound like
somewhere anyone would actually
want to live.
But I suppose we should all
be thinking our lucky stars
that we're not there
yet, not even close.
Thank you.
- Let me just tell you a
little bit about Claire.
She is the author of
several works of fiction.
I assume many in the audience
have read them, most recently,
The Woman Upstairs, which
was published in 2013.
Two of her novels, The Hunters
and When the World Was Steady
were finalists for the
PEN/Faulkner prize for fiction.
Claire has been a longtime
friend of Radcliffe,
as I mentioned before.
She was a fellow
from 2004 to 2005.
And she's stayed involved
with the Institute, which
we're very pleased about.
While she was here, she worked
on a novel called The Emperor's
Children, also set in New York
during another tumultuous time,
the period surrounding the
attacks on the World Trade
Center towers in 2001.
And The Emperor's
Children was named
one of the top 10 best books
of 2006 by The New York Times.
Now, I'm going to
move over here.
I did bring-- this
is the paperback,
so we don't give quite--
it's not quite fair.
Yours was pretty big,
when it was in hardback.
- A lot of smaller.
A lot smaller.
- But I'd like to
just start, Claire.
We've heard from
Garth, and I should
say that when Garth
accepted our invitation,
we were very excited.
And he was very open to the
idea of having a conversation,
not just giving a lecture.
And it immediately
came to me that Claire
was the perfect person to be in
conversation, because she too
had written a book
about New York
at a very particular
moment in time.
So I'd like to start by
asking you, Claire, to give us
a little sense of
your own story, of how
you came to Emperor's
Children, why New York.
You too are not a
New Yorker by birth.
You, as I understand it,
you're part Canadian.
Your mother's Canadian.
Your father was French Algerian?
- He's French.
- French.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- Why this book?
And why this time?
- Well, I mean,
it's interesting.
Maybe Garth in a
minute will tell us
a little more about how City
on Fire came out of 9/11.
- Because you have that
in your book as well.
- Well, it happens.
You know, it just
happens at the end.
But I had started a
novel set in New York,
and then 9/11 happened.
And then I had to throw away
what I had, and think maybe
I would write something
else, or maybe
I would-- maybe we
would never write again.
Maybe it was a time for
poetry, and prose was finished.
- Hopefully not irony, right?
- And then when I
began with a sense
that The Emperor's Children is
a sort of August 1914 novel.
It's about the time
before coming to an end,
and I remember one of the
reviewers saying in irritation
you know for almost
all of the book it just
seems like any ordinary year.
But of course, if you
remember back to 2001
until September 11,
it really just did
seem like any ordinary year,
which was sort of the point.
I had wanted to write a novel
set in the city about people
in the city.
And that was in
part, because it's
true-- I was not
born in New York.
My father worked in New York.
My parents lived in Connecticut.
I went to college
in New Haven, and I
went then went off to
graduate school in England,
and all my friends
moved to New York.
And I kept thinking there's
my life, waiting for me.
There is my life.
It'll still be there.
My life is waiting.
But somehow I never
got there, so I
thought well, I'd better just
make up a story about it.
- I'd like to follow up on--
I was going to ask you what
Claire alluded to, which is
that many critics have said that
even though your book is set
in the 1970s and the event that
disrupts the world that you've
created is the blackout,
that in many ways that was kind
of a proxy for 9/11 in many
ways.
And so could you talk a
little bit about that?
- Well, do you
remember that there
was that whole thing
in 2002 and 2003,
almost comical, of
like people wringing
their hands in the
newspaper, and like, oh,
when will the fiction writers
weigh in on September 11, which
was kind of odd,
because you were like,
do you people know how long?
- Right, I mean, when did
the Vietnam stories come?
- And so I remember when your
book came out, which was 2006,
and like really appreciating
how deftly it handled that,
because it does have such
a large impact on even
just the plot, in a way.
And I stole something
from you, so thank you.
Yeah, I mean, just
the way that you
throw a catastrophe in the
middle of an urban environment,
and the characters can't
get to each other, which
can be really awkward
depending on where they are
and where they're
supposed to be.
But what I specifically
admired was exactly that,
it did not feel like a
novel about September 11.
And the only successful
things that I've
read that really went right
at it are, I think arguably,
Deborah Eisenberg's story,
Twilight of the Superheroes
and more arguably
DeLillo's Falling Man.
And I would argue for.
But I really wanted
to resist that,
and yet I was changed so
much as a person by that.
I know, partly by
virtue of it really
being-- I mean it would've
been like turning 22 in August
of 1914, and leaving college,
like a kind of Hans Castorp
thing, like, here's
the world, and it just
is completely not what
you were expecting.
That I couldn't not
get it into the novel,
and so somehow I
was wanting to write
about a city at a time of
crisis, but not this crisis.
And something came to me.
- OK, that makes sense.
So let's talk a little bit
more about New York, which
figures into both of
your books, and you
were suggesting, even in
some ways taught you--
as you talked about
Jane Jacobs-- about how
to write a novel in
terms of the qualities.
Is New York just a setting?
Is it a character?
Is it one thing?
Is it a very fragmented
sort of place
that people experience
very differently?
Tell us about how
what New York meant
to you in writing these novels?
- Well, I was just
curious, because I
had assumed that
you had lived in New
York for some period of
time because the novel is
very persuasive in that way.
- People still say I'll
send it to you in New York.
And I say, no, I
don't live there.
- So someone who didn't live
there, how do you see it?
- Well, as I said, I
feel I didn't live there,
but I lived there, if
you know what I mean.
My father worked at 50th and
Third Avenue for 15 years.
I think there were so many
things about your novel and so
many questions I'd love to
ask you in terms of the city
and you imagining the city in
the 1970s, which of course you
are too young to
have experienced
in any conscious way.
But I have memories of-- I
was at boarding school here
between 1980 and 1983.
And going to stay with
friends in New York,
and it was the time when you
went to stay with friends,
and their parents
were just away.
You were 14 years old, staying,
their parents were just away.
Yeah, that doesn't happen
now, I think, in the same way.
But you really
captured that aspect
of the city, and of course,
for me at least, place
is always a character.
It's how much of
a character it is,
and New York being so diverse,
concrete, and enormous
is going to be a huge character.
But for you, it wasn't a random
choice to choose the '70s.
How did you?
That New York is such
a particular New York.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Do you get the sense sometimes
of-- I mean and this is
a little trite but-- of having
the material kind of choose
you.
I'm not a very
rational-- I'm not
a very administrative
or top-down thinker.
I tend to sort of
wander around confused,
and then it's
like, oh, I suppose
I have to write that story.
- But I know that I have
to write that story,
but the thing of New
York, of the city,
and of the diversity
of the city,
and of the as it were the
Hamilton-Sweeneys' Sutton Place
house and the squat.
And just things like
Tompkins Square Park,
right, when I was
in college, there
were riots in
Tompkins Square Park.
I think by the time
that was in my novel,
Mr. Giuliani had made sure.
He had evacuated--
- Condos in the center
of Tompkins Square Park--
- All problematic
citizens, or subcitizens,
as he might see them,
in order to make sure
there were not more riots
ever in Tompkins Square Park.
But you had to re-imagine
yourself back into it.
- Well, there's that essay
that Benjamin's Arcades Project
sort of erupts out
of, that was to be
called Paris, the Capital
of the 19th Century.
And one does have the
feeling that the 20th century
version will be New York, the
Capital of the 20th Century.
And it's interesting.
The analysis that
Benjamin gets is actually
very, very specific.
It's not just any old
place, or it's not just
the biggest one of these things.
It has its own character.
And there is something for
me about the 20th century
having been a century of tribes
suddenly mixing together.
It's probably the most murderous
century we've had so far,
although that's probably true
of every century, sad to say.
But at the same time, there's a
sense of also the 20th century
is the one in which it
was suddenly conceivable
that people of
different sexualities,
ethnic backgrounds, classes
might-- that period you
were describing,
I think, there was
less of the social liberation,
although that was coming.
I think you would
still in the '60s
have rather been in New York
than Alabama if you are gay.
But there was this
sense of an experiment,
like a crazy experiment.
How did you put it?
You said the something
equality and some social?
- Social responsibility
and fiscal responsibility--
- Were kind of in
collision in the 1970s.
And the argument's being
made that what was ultimately
most socially
responsible will be what
was most fiscally responsible.
I mean, those were very
important conversations
that people had.
- And somehow the whole
social side of the city,
the whole drawing together of
these great masses of people
from all over the world was
also underwriting and was
underwritten by this huge
economic miracle-- I mean,
what now looks to
us like a miracle.
Back then, you would
have just thought,
oh, this is every day life.
And what interested me, I
guess, about this period is--
in the novel and what interests
me about like this week
is-- it's one of those moments
where the inherent tensions
erupt and the question of is it
possible for things that go on
like this comes to the fore?
- It strikes me that you
both have protagonists
who are young people.
And so some of this feeling
one's way in the city
is a young person's project.
So you have Mercer, the
aspiring writer who comes,
who in many ways may be you,
who comes from the rural South
to the city, going to write
the great American novel.
You have William,
the alienated heir
to this family fortune
that his sister,
trying to live an ordinary life.
Samantha and Charlie,
suburban kids
from Long Island, who
see New York as the way
to escape suburbia
and live a real life.
And you too build
your novel around
these privileged graduates
of Brown University who
come to New York
with great dreams
but they don't seem to
be getting anywhere.
And then there's the
more working class
cousin from New York.
But these are all young
people, for whom the city seems
to hold out these promises.
Was that a deliberate decision?
How did you particularly,
Claire, come to that decision
that you would get a novel
that would culminate in 9/11
would be about young
people's dilemmas?
- Liz, I was young.
Really, I think the
city is obviously--
exactly what Garth was talking
about in the early part
of your talk-- this repository
of dream and fantasy.
And from Balzac onwards,
from Lost Delusions onwards,
the idea of the provincial
comes to the city
and discovers all of the
things-- the diversity,
and the corruption, and
vice for the first time,
but also ambition.
And I'd actually be
really interested to read
the novel about the
55-year-old doing that.
I mean, I think it'd be a
really interesting novel,
but it isn't an instinctive.
- I actually really
like that idea.
- But I think there is
the buoyancy of the city
and the maelstrom is
like the cliche-- oh,
that's a young person's
thing to move to New York.
- It's interesting.
When I was suggesting
that maybe it's
not just that New York happens
to be the biggest game in town
in the 20th century,
but that it actually
has its own kind of
personality, that that's maybe
a distinction that I would
make between New York and, say,
Chicago, or Baltimore,
or Memphis, or something.
There's a youth
culture-- I mean,
there always has been--
that draws people there.
Also it's the city
of reinvention.
Like you maybe go
to Chicago to work
on the Mercantile Exchange.
I love Chicago.
If you're an actor,
you go to Chicago.
But in most ways,
you come to New York.
And Paris was that
in the 19th century.
- And Berlin is that
to some extent now.
And I think there's
also this sense of--
- Berlin and-- God help
us-- San Francisco.
- Well, but I going say that
I think one of the things,
maybe not to
Francisco any longer,
because-- the French word
that is in my head is
[SPEAKING FRENCH] and even if
you were telling your story
about we couldn't afford
to go to grad school.
We couldn't afford.
That was my story too,
I couldn't afford.
I could afford to
live in London.
It used to be cheap.
But I couldn't afford
to live in New York.
And I think that
part of the is what
you're willing to put up
with when you're young.
Is it Jenny's first flat
that has the bathtub.
I remember them, the
bathtub under the counter.
- I had pages and
pages that I had
to cut, just all those little--
- You cut pages, Garth?
- I cut so many pages.
It was twice as long.
- But what you'd put up
with to be in New York.
And that's part of the
exhilaration and thrill of it.
But rare is the 55-year-old
will put up with it.
- Though it was also a time
of when there were many ways
to live in New York.
And it seems now there
are increasingly fewer.
Brooklyn is no longer
what Brooklyn was.
I don't know what the new
affordable part of New York
is, but your people are living
in all different kinds of ways
in New York-- group
houses and whatever.
So but I did want to weave
just a little more time
for our discussion
before we open it up.
I gather from some
of the articles
I've read that Scott Rudin has
picked up the rights to make
a film, based on the book.
And I'm curious
about whether that
is in fact happening,
what your expectations are
about the film.
In many ways, the
novel is a product
of the 19th century-- television
and film, 20th and 21st.
Do you think that the
film by definition
will have to be very different?
It will be shorter, unless
you're planning for--
- Better be in a
miniseries, don't you think?
They can't do it in two hours.
- So what's the plan?
And did you actually have any
film interest in your book?
- Yes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Long and boring story.
- Claire and I know each
other just well enough,
I presume, for her to
know that I am very, very
deliberate about a lot of
choices that I make, let's say.
And I've noticed that you
look at certain writers'
bibliographies.
Notice an eight or nine year
gap, and you go what happened?
And you start to
ask around, and it's
like, oh, they got sucked
into the screenplay dungeon
or whatever.
So my policy following having
used older writers by proxy
is to remain as remote
as I can possibly be.
- So you will not be involved
in-- but it isn't happening?
You don't know.
- I wouldn't know.
- But may I ask-- it couldn't
be for a two hour film.
It would have to be something.
I think that's--
- There's a two-hour film in
there just struggling to get
out.
- We cut 200 characters.
They're not on the [INAUDIBLE]
- The blackout will
probably come a lot sooner.
- Well, how do you make
a movie about a blackout?
The whole thing third act.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Avant-garde.
- So Claire, what's
your story with film?
- I think it was a long
process where it was optioned,
and then, one set
of people get--
you can't imagine how many
times I've read in Variety about
the imminent filming of my book.
But lo and behold, the house
of cards doesn't stay up.
You have to let it go.
It's a different medium.
If they're going to make
a movie-- in my case
I think at this point I can say
with confidence they're not--
but if they're going
to make a movie,
they have to be
free to adapt it.
And there's that wonderful
story about Nabokov writing
the screenplay for
Lolita and them
saying thank you, thank
you, wonderful, wonderful.
And as he walked out, tearing
it up and beginning again.
It's just such a
different medium,
and any filmmaker
will need the leeway
to do whatever
they're going to do.
But you might be surprised
and find that City on Fire
is Berlin.
I mean, it could happen.
- Oh, right, that they'll
make that dramatic a change.
- I think it's just a
completely different--
- Werner, and Hans,
and all of that.
- Though it does strike me that
this appetite people have now
for these series, and watching
they will just sit there
and watch one show after
another of-- we're all doing it.
And there's a lot of attention.
That's where the writing
talent is now in television,
not movies, and all that.
- But just to say a little
something about that,
there was this big-- at the time
I sat down to write the book--
there was this big
narrative about--
it was like bookstores
were going bankrupt.
Publishers were not far behind.
And everyone was said to be
unable to sustain attention
for more than 140 characters.
- And you thought
I'll prove them wrong.
- Au contraire.
I thought, oh, this
novel was unpublishable.
But the punk in me
was like, perfect,
then I don't have to worry
about what Heidegger called das
Mann, like the they, the them.
What do they think?
It was just what
does the book want?
But I did notice everyone
was on their 53rd
hour of The Sopranos, which is a
remarkable feat of achievement.
- Or The Wire or The Americans.
- And I had this feeling,
watching those shows that they
had stolen an entire-- or
not stolen, appropriated--
adapted an entire grammar
from the novel that I loved
and could be put to deeper
purposes in the novel,
because of just what is unique
about the novel as a form.
And I did have this
feeling of well, you know,
I'm taking these things back.
And by the time I
got out of my garret
with my incredibly unwieldy
manuscript, I looked around
and suddenly people
were going to bookstores
and that meant large,
ambitious novels were--
- Change had been happening.
- Yes.
- So maybe these series
are sending us back
to the long book, which I do
want to close on just asking,
and then we'll open it up.
The mic is in the aisle.
So this is a long
book, and you've
suggested that you have even
cut, that it was even longer,
and you've cut it.
Why is it such a long book?
And I am curious.
- I think if you have
to ask that question,
it's not a successful book.
- No, did you worry
that if it was too long,
you would lose these
readers who were--
- Claire--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- You reviewed Teju
Cole's Open City, right?
- I did, yeah.
- Wonderful book.
And I read it, and I just
thought, what an elegant way
of going at urban experience.
And I thought, why am I not
smart enough to do that?
I don't have the talent to adopt
that kind of economy of means.
But what I was specifically
interested in about the city
was the ways that they teeter
on the edge of falling apart,
the ways that they come
right up against the boundary
conditions for
their own existence,
by attempting to do too much and
be too much to too many people.
And so I wanted to make
a city out of prose,
and actually, like at a
certain point, I cut back.
This is the organized
complexity thing.
I cut back to a certain thing,
and it and it fell apart.
It wouldn't hold
together anymore.
And I had to actually
work back out
to something slightly larger.
And it was like really
just fascinating
and a little bit baffling
to me, but I just knew.
I was like, oh, it dies
with too much constraint.
- It's about you have
to hit the balance.
- You wanted to say something.
- I just wanted
to respond to that
and say I disagree with your
framing of why you didn't
write a book like Open City.
- Well, I'm being a little--
- Yeah, you're throwing
on the self-deprecation.
You don't need to do that.
- My hair shirt.
- But it is true
that there are two--
it is the novel of the
flaneur, as it were,
and it is the city
as an interior space.
The city as interiority,
as opposed to the city
as the teeming,
diverse, concrete world.
And I think it's just actually a
different novelistic tradition,
in which you have as many
certainly as many ideas
and as much
interiority and as much
history, and a whole
lot else besides.
It's just a different approach.
And I do think that balance
of constraint and freedom--
it makes total sense that
it's like a geodesic dome
or something.
You have to get the
proportions right.
But I know we need to
move out to the audience.
One tiny question
that I have for you
is that I know when
I start something,
I usually have a
sense of its scale.
And I wondered if from the very
moment you envisaged you knew?
- You did.
- I did.
- That's why you put it in
a drawer for three years.
- Yeah, it was two minutes and
45 seconds in July of 2003,
I thought aha.
And it ended up almost exactly
page count, word count, all
those things, what I imagined.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- So now it's your turn.
Please come up to
the mic in the aisle.
Introduce yourself, tell us who
you are, and ask your question.
- A question I have
for both of you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Your name?
- I'm [? Nadal ?] [? Zovik. ?]
I wonder if the city are dying
in some very unique
way right now.
I would like to
have your opinion.
If you look to the influence in
money and technology right now,
Paris, London, I know really
well about Venice, but also
New York, real estate
has become an investment.
You have in these
big cities apartment
that are empty that people
buy, and they don't live there.
And that this has
become a trend.
Then people who don't have a big
income cannot live in the city
anymore.
It's about money and technology.
Bookstores are disappearing.
I imagine a city where Amazon
packages would be delivered
all through the city
but there would not
be stores anymore,
no more bookstores.
I was absent for three
months, and when I came back
to Cambridge-- I don't know if
you are familiar with Harvard
Square-- I was in shock.
Holyoke is the center
of Harvard Square,
where Holyoke Center is.
All the trees has been cut down,
and there's plywood everywhere.
Places where I used to
go as a grad student,
just to run for a coffee,
sit, read the newspaper,
or discuss with
friend-- it was all
gone in very short
period of time.
Out of town news [INAUDIBLE]
middle of Harvard Square,
like an institution.
We are hearing voices
that it's going to close,
because it's a
prime real estate.
So where is this city going to?
I would like to know
your opinion, thank you.
- I'll turn it over to
you, but I would just say--
to come back to Garth's
point about constant change--
I was in boarding school
here in 1980 to 1983.
Harvard Square was
under construction.
And I went away for 20
years, and I came back,
and Harvard Square was
under construction.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- The Mug and Muffin was gone,
but I mean, things do change.
I know exactly what you're
saying about money and cities,
and I think there
are obviously very
important conversations
to be had about that
and work to be done.
On the other hand, people
are moving to cities
in unprecedented numbers.
Are we not reaching
a point where
more than half our
population is in cities now?
People are fleeing the vast red
map, precisely for the cities.
And not everybody's rich.
So it seems to me that
one of the things that
does happen that
hopefully is to the good
is that there isn't just
Paris, and New York,
and London, and Berlin,
but also Austin, Texas, and
Philadelphia, and Seattle,
and Atlanta, and so on.
- Now, I could say
having recently
been to all these cities
that Seattle's unaffordable.
Austin's getting unaffordable.
But you have to read
Jane Jacobs on this,
because I think there's a
chapter about-- I think she
calls it catastrophic money.
And she talks about one
of the neighborhoods
she uses is the South
End, I think, of Boston
and how the magic of this
specific confluence of factors
that makes it wonderful
at a certain time
will eventually lure
in-- it will become
a commodity for those who can
afford it, and then kill what
was great in the first place.
That's just sort of the cycle.
But there are places.
I spent a lot of the first
part of the year traveling
around Europe.
Berlin is an amazing city,
because you can throw anything
at it, and it's so big that
it just sort of swallows it.
But Lisbon, Budapest-- there
are a number of other cities
that they're not on our maps.
They're not on my map, because
I'm old and boring now.
But if I was young,
that would be the place.
And those places
will get settled,
and then the catastrophic
money will flow towards those.
So I don't know that
trying to manage it
by freezing cities
in place-- there's
a degree to which that works,
like Jackie Kennedy stopping
the destruction of
Grand Central Station.
But there's a degree to
which it's a losing battle
to try to just
freeze it in place.
And I think what I
was trying to suggest
is we have to oppose
a vision of change
to the change that's happening,
rather than opposing it
with sort of fixity.
- I'm Jonas.
How much research did
you do for this book?
And did the research
change the path
for some of your
characters in smaller ways,
like was that store on
that street and so on?
- I mean I'll just
disappoint you.
I'm not a big researcher
as a novelist.
Someone asked E.L. Doctorow
about how much research
did you do-- fabulously
persuasive fictional edifices
set in historical periods--
and he said, how much did I do?
I did just enough, just
enough to persuade you.
Our art is not an art of fact.
It's an art of belief.
And I did this interview
with Javier Marias on Friday,
and he did this
amazing Marias thing
where he flipped it around, and
we got to where we were like,
oh, belief is more
real than fact.
He had me totally persuaded.
I have no idea what he
said, but we're working in--
- Well, but it's clearly
true in our new America.
- Yeah, well, it's probably
always been true in some way.
But the rhetoric of fiction is
very, very interesting thing
to think about.
And as novelists,
we think about it.
And I think it's almost
something that never occurs
to the reader, but--
just for example,
it seems intuitive that
the more research you do,
the more persuasive
something becomes.
And yet often the more you pile
up, the more anxious you seem.
I think James has written
really well on this.
The more anxious you
seem to show the reader.
You lose the
authority that comes
from feeling like, I got this.
I know this cold.
I didn't live in New
York, but I know it.
I wasn't alive, and I was
born at the end of the '70s,
but I know them.
And so I felt that the whole
fiction-making mechanism
would somehow be
paralyzed if I backed up
my dump truck of research.
And in fact, you
get to facts that
are true on the
level of research
but false to people's memories.
And then they'll
treat them as false,
even though they're true.
So what I did instead was
I tried to write the book,
and trust my imagination, and
trust the things that would
pop out at the end of my pen.
And then when I had a
draft, I did go back.
I wanted to know if
the store had moved,
but I wouldn't
necessarily change it.
I'm unwilling to let things be.
- But there's a
kind of authenticity
you knew you had to create,
even if it wasn't accuracy.
Those are different.
- That word authenticity
is so problematic in a way
that no one talks about.
But I never questioned the
authenticity of your New York.
And now that I know that you
didn't spend a lot of time
living there, if I was a
certain kind of critic,
I know I would be tempted
to be like, is it authentic?
But it has the
authenticity of belief,
and the authenticity
of persuasion,
of imagination.
And that's the only
authenticity there really is.
I hate to burst anyone's bubble.
But I got this from
watching Patty Smith.
The performance is
the authenticity.
There's nothing.
There's no non-performed thing.
- I read an interview in which
you said something that's
very similar to one
of my favorite things
that Peter Carey
said about writing
Oscar and Lucinda, where he
said I looked at it as a science
fiction of the past.
And you started by
saying as a kid,
you loved reading books
that built worlds,
and I think that's what fiction
does, is build the world.
And if it builds a
world successfully,
you're ready to jump in.
As a reader, you're
ready to jump in.
And I think then it
isn't-- as you say--
it isn't about the
minutiae so much.
- And conversely, if you
build in a kickstand,
so that it's kind of
leaning on the real world,
it doesn't work.
It has to be autonomous, even
if everything in it is 100%.
So Wolf Hall is an amazing--
I could have never done that.
And you know everything
in it is true.
I mean, you just know she
did a ton of research,
and she wasn't paralyzed by
it, because she's not me.
And yet it's
completely autonomous.
It is sufficient unto itself,
and if Cromwell had never
existed, it wouldn't
be any less of a novel.
- It would be as convincing.
And the historical
novel I always think of
is The Blue Flower, which for
me is Penelope Fitzgerald's
The Blue Flower, which is
the ideal historical novel,
in which the
historicity-- is that
appropriate in this context?
I'm not sure.
But it is so profoundly
embedded that you forget
that it's a historical novel.
Then there's a moment
where they some weird sort
of late 18th century soup.
You know, like, oh,
I guess it isn't now.
- It's so real.
- But it's not calling
attention to itself.
- And as a genre, maybe this
is why I usually rebel against
the-- like I don't think of this
as a historical novel at all.
And it's a genre I tend
to have a lot of problems
with, because it generally
tends to want to lean
on the real world for a prop.
But the great artists
who do it, it--
- It lifts off.
- Well, we are out of time.
And I just want to
ask you to join me
in thanking Claire and Garth
for this very [INAUDIBLE]